There's a tipping point.
It was corruption much direction before you hit that tipping point.
And so what that means is the moral behavior of each individual is far more
important that people generally think,
cause it doesn't take many cheaters getting away with it to make those who don't
cheat think that they're fools.
It's the probability of being caught.
That's the deterrent,
isn't the severity of the punishment.
Okay.
We know that that doesn't,
that isn't questionable.
We know that that's the case.
And I don't know why conservatives don't,
the reason they don't get it is because they vote by,
you know,
they think by their temperament and their temperament says punish.
It's not thinking it's just a temperamental response.
Whereas the liberal responses,
well,
you know,
those poor criminals must've had something happened to them that was terrible in
their past or they wouldn't be criminals,
which is,
you know,
just equally as nonsensical.
Yeah.